hi right near David Tonya Hart American
urban radio networks how are you
congratulations and I loved the piece in
yesterday's New York Times with you and
Diane about the whole fashion thing when
you were creating all of this in your
mind how important was fashioned
familiar obviously a lot but what what
did you really hone in on it you know
the whole secret of the cinema that
we've been doing for the last three
motion pictures the fighter silver
linings playbook and American hustle is
a soulful kind of feeling for the human
beings and like I said to Diane von
Furstenberg was an enormous hero to me I
was so excited I got to meet her you
know so we have a couple of her vintage
dresses in the movie is their jersey and
you can feel people through the the
dress it's like feels like their skin
and it's unpretentious but it's elegant
so to me I think about I love that my
mom had that dress my high school
girlfriend had that dress the wrap dress
it was all very personal to me you know
my dad had a comb-over so you know it's
all about having love for the characters
from the inside that's what the whole
thing is to me and how they love life
and live life and struggle that's the
whole thing
I david jason nathan some of ABC news
radio back here I love chanting that
could have directed this film at the
beginning of your career you need the
experience that you had a long way to
get this oh I definitely am a late
bloomer and I definitely needed to grow
up which happened between the first set
of movies and the second set of movies
in the first set of movies and ending
with Huckabee's which I would say in the
in the pad twelve Irving Rosenfeld which
was Christian Bale gave us that from Bob
Hoskins who said it about acting from
the ears up is one thing from the feet
up is a different thing I would say the
cinema of the last three pictures has
really been from the feet up in terms of
great passion for every detail of every
character and great instinct so yes
that's a that answers your question
right was very different so I feel very
clear and that can only happen after
you've been humbled or struggled and got
you know got your head on straight and
you can relate to characters who have
gone through that
we're going first online have problems
well I've seen it so many times I mean
my own mom reinvented herself my own
parents were immigrant kids they were
the first generation Americans who
reinvented themselves in the world of
publishing she was a secretary of Simon
& Schuster and my dad was a salesman and
they they were respectively the son of a
tally invoke maker and a hum and a
butcher a Russian butcher and they
completely had to reinvent themselves
with their wardrobe and start wearing
tweeds and we were the first family to
move to a suburb which was you know we
were sort of the ones with the New York
accents who didn't fit in and that was a
big journey so I relate to that deeply
and personally and my own self you know
I've had to see my son go through many
reincarnations get many second third and
fourth chances due to his challenges and
he taught me you can't afford to have a
negative attitude or as Jack Nicholson
has famously said try to incline
yourself upwards as much as possible
because the world will easily incline
you downwards so I i feel that a second
third and fourth chances are what it's
all about and I love watching people
pick themselves up and that's what the
cinemas about thank you guys